do you believe
um
uh the story of Virgin birth Mary what
are your thoughts like Do You Believe In
The credibility of that story do I
believe it's a fact or do I believe it's
truth do do you believe well what's the
difference that's the key okay so is
what's the difference a fact is a thing
it can't be debated right a fact is a
thing that can be scientifically
verified okay right that's that's what
we Now understand a truth it doesn't
necessarily have to do with fact truth
is a far deeper well both ways what do
you think about it no there's there's no
fact whatsoever about the Virgin birth
it exists in one section of the entire
uh uh gospels okay
um no one else mentions it uh Matthew
doesn't mention it it's just Justin Luke
uh that means 90 A.D so 60 years after
Jesus's death we can go back to the
writings that we find you know a little
bit earlier there's some writings of
Paul in in 50s virgin birth is never
mentioned in those in those writings
this was the Virgin birth was a problem
that arose out of Paul
because Paul who never met Jesus never
spoke to Jesus had nothing to do with
Jesus whatsoever but who claims to have
had this uh experience of the Risen
Jesus long after
Jesus died in which uh according to him
Jesus makes him the sort of the 13th
Apostle right an apostle was somebody
who walked and talked with Jesus and
there were 12 of them and Paul who
neither walked nor talked with Jesus
says that that the Risen Christ turned
him into the 13th Apostle and gave him
this new message
and Paul goes around and he starts
preaching this version of Jesus that the
apostles
had never heard of before Jesus wasn't
even a man in Paul's view Jesus was born
of pure light he is a new genus of being
he came to Earth as this sort of
begotten the the only begotten Son of
God in order to uh to deal with original
sin again Jesus never mentioned anything
about original sin it's not in any of
the gospels and Paul's imagination when
Adam and Eve fell all human beings were
born in sin and Jesus's death
cleared that sin for everyone for all of
time this is Paul has no one except Paul
had ever said or thought anything like
this it was the first time these words
were ever written it's now basic
Christianity but here's the problem
if everyone who is born is born of sin
until Jesus is born and rids everyone of
sin then Jesus can't be born
Paul himself never said Jesus can't be
born he just let the contradiction live
but then later on
by the time you get to the 90s
in answer to to criticism an answer to
critics saying wait a minute what are
you talking about like then doesn't make
any sense he himself was born then he
had sin was this new idea that no no
Jesus wasn't born in the in the same way
he was born of a virgin it's mentioned
once it's mentioned in the year 90. and
there's no reason to think that it's
anything other than what it sounds like
an answer to a problem so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]